Hello, I'm Audrey Hamilton. Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, a podcast from the American Psychological Association. The anxiety of a new school year can affect almost any student. They may be worried about which teachers they'll have or the prospect of meeting new classmates. For students with autism spectrum disorder, meeting new people and making friends is especially challenging. In this episode, we'll hear from Dr. Elizabeth Loggison, a psychologist who runs the program for the education and enrichment of relational skills, or peers. at UCLA, where the latest autism behavioral research is used to help teens make and keep friends. Elizabeth Loggison is a licensed clinical psychologist and assistant clinical professor of psychiatry
你好，我是奥黛丽·汉密尔顿。欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会推出的一档播客。新学年的焦虑几乎会影响到每一位学生。他们可能会担心自己会遇到什么样的老师，或者担心结识新同学的前景。对于患有自闭症谱系障碍的学生来说，结识新朋友和交友尤其具有挑战性。在这一集中，我们将采访加州大学洛杉矶分校（UCLA）的伊丽莎白·洛吉森博士，她负责管理“关系技能教育与充实项目”（PEERS），该项目利用最新的自闭症行为研究来帮助青少年结交并维持友谊。伊丽莎白·洛吉森是一位持证临床心理学家，也是精神病学助理临床教授
and biobehavioral sciences at UCLA. She is the founder and director of the UCLA Peers Clinic, where she works directly with teens and young adults with autism spectrum disorder. Her research, investigating social skills training for youth from preschool to early adulthood, has been widely published and recognized. Her studies have been funded by the National Institutes of Health and Centers for Disease Control and Prevention. Welcome, Dr. Loggison. Thank you for having me. The program you lead at UCLA, the Peers Program, focuses on improving social skills among high-functioning adolescents with autism, using evidence-based training.
以及加州大学洛杉矶分校的行为生物科学教授。她是加州大学洛杉矶分校PEERS诊所的创始人和主任，在那里她直接与患有自闭症谱系障碍的青少年和年轻人一起工作。她研究青少年从学龄前到成年早期的社交技能训练，研究成果已被广泛发表并获得认可。她的研究得到了美国国立卫生研究院和疾病控制与预防中心的资助。欢迎您，洛吉森博士。谢谢你邀请我。您在加州大学洛杉矶分校领导的PEERS项目，利用循证训练，专注于提高高功能自闭症青少年的社交技能。
Can you give us some real-life examples of how this program works? Sure, absolutely. You know, one of the things that we really focus on in peers is not just social skills, which is rather broad, but really making and keeping friends. We know that having a few close friends in adolescence and adulthood is really critical to later adjustment in life. And so the types of skills that we focus on are things like conversational skills, knowing how to go up to a group of people and join their conversation, how to assess whether or not
您能给我们举一些现实生活中的例子来说明这个项目是如何运作的吗？当然，绝对可以。你知道，我们在PEERS中真正关注的不仅仅是社交技能（这个概念比较宽泛），而是真正地结交并维持友谊。我们知道，在青春期和成年期拥有几个亲密朋友对于以后的人生适应至关重要。因此，我们关注的技能类型包括对话技巧，比如知道如何走向一群人并加入他们的谈话，如何评估自己是否
you're accepted into those conversations. And if you're not how to exit the conversations, we also talk about things like having get-togethers and developing closer, more meaningful friendships with people, as well as handling things like peer rejection and peer conflict. Why do autistic children need social skills training specifically, and when have you seen them gain from it? Well, you know, social skill deficits are one of the hallmark features in autism across the spectrum. And the way that that sort of manifests itself is in difficulty with things like social communication, knowing how to have a conversation with someone. Also social awareness, so really understanding the social landscape in which you live,
被那些谈话所接纳。如果没被接纳，该如何退出谈话。我们还讨论诸如聚会、与人建立更亲密、更有意义的友谊，以及处理同伴拒绝和同伴冲突等问题。为什么自闭症儿童特别需要社交技能训练？您在什么时候看到他们从中受益？嗯，你知道，社交技能缺陷是自闭症在整个谱系中的标志性特征之一。这种缺陷的表现形式是社交沟通方面的困难，比如不知道如何与人交谈。还有社交意识，即真正理解你所处的社交环境，
kind of picking up on social cues. We know that our kids really struggle with social, you know, motivation, wanting to actually engage their peers, as well as social cognition, which is another one of those hallmark features of autism. And that's basically difficulty kind of putting yourself in someone else's shoes, understanding the perspectives of others. So we know that adolescents and adults with autism really struggle socially. And so, of course, we want to intervene and help them in this, you know, very vital and important area. Can you talk about what it is? is about this disorder that makes it so difficult for them to maintain friendships and engage with others their age? I think difficulty with conversational skills, for example, makes it very, very
捕捉社交线索。我们知道我们的孩子在社交动机方面确实很挣扎，即想要真正与同伴互动，以及社交认知，这也是自闭症的标志性特征之一。这基本上就是难以设身处地为他人着想，理解他人的观点。所以我们知道，患有自闭症的青少年和成年人在社交方面确实很挣扎。因此，我们当然希望进行干预，帮助他们在这一非常重要和关键的领域取得进步。您能谈谈这个障碍到底是什么，使得他们如此难以维持友谊并与同龄人互动吗？我认为，例如，对话技巧方面的困难使得它变得非常非常
difficult to develop meaningful and close relationships with people, whether they be friendships or romantic relationships, and difficulty picking up on social cues and understanding the perspectives of others, knowing how someone might actually react to something that we say or something that we do. That sort of difficulty makes it really challenging for people with autism to develop these relationships. And you talk about engaging and even having a real conversation, but these days, there's cyberbullying, there's social media. I mean, how is that challenging for autistic teens when it comes to making friends and interacting? It's interesting about kids with autism is that they very often gravitate towards technology and computers and, you know, being on the Internet. But interestingly enough, they're not that engaged in traditional forms of social media,
难以与人建立有意义和亲密的关系，无论是友谊还是浪漫关系，以及难以捕捉社交线索和理解他人的观点，不知道别人对我们所说或所做的事情会有什么反应。这种困难使得自闭症患者建立这些关系变得非常具有挑战性。您谈到了互动，甚至进行真正的对话，但现在有网络欺凌，有社交媒体。我的意思是，当涉及到结交朋友和互动时，这对自闭症青少年来说有多大的挑战？关于自闭症儿童，有趣的是，他们经常倾向于技术、电脑和上网。但有趣的是，他们并不太参与传统的社交媒体形式，
like a lot of kids are on Facebook, for example. But our kids in the spectrum don't tend to be involved in things like Facebook, those types of social media. They do tend to gravitate towards things like online gaming, things like World of Warcraft and Minecraft and things like that. But there's not as much social interaction in those types of forums. When our kids are, though, involved with types of social media like Facebook, they are more. prone to actually being cyber bullied very sadly by their peers. And so there's many different, you know, hypotheses about why that might be. But again, knowing that our kids aren't quite as socially savvy and aren't necessarily picking up on the same cues that the rest of us might be picking up on,
比如很多孩子都在用的Facebook。但我们谱系中的孩子往往不参与Facebook这类社交媒体。他们确实倾向于倾向于网络游戏，比如《魔兽世界》和《我的世界》之类的游戏。但在这些类型的论坛中，社交互动并不多。不过，当我们的孩子参与Facebook这类社交媒体时，他们确实更容易受到同伴的网暴，这非常令人难过。所以，关于为什么会这样，有很多不同的假设。但同样，知道我们的孩子在社交上不够精明，不一定能捕捉到我们其他人可能捕捉到的相同线索，
they do become easier targets for bullying. So one of the things that we do in peers is we actually target that type of peer rejection and give them strategies for how to handle cyberbullying. Well, going back to the program itself, I know that it relies a lot on role-playing to help students understand how to behave. What are some examples of these social situations they face during training? Well, I'm glad you asked. I love talking about the program and the skills that we teach. You know, we basically teach two types of skills. We teach sort of how to develop meaningful relationships with other people. And we also teach our kids how to handle things like peer rejection and peer conflict,
他们确实更容易成为欺凌的目标。所以我们在PEERS中所做的事情之一，就是专门针对那种同伴拒绝，并给他们提供如何处理网络欺凌的策略。回到项目本身，我知道它非常依赖角色扮演来帮助学生理解如何表现。他们在训练中面临的这些社交情境有哪些例子？嗯，很高兴你问这个问题。我喜欢谈论这个项目和我们教授的技能。你知道，我们基本上教授两种类型的技能。我们教授如何与他人建立有意义的关系。我们也教我们的孩子如何处理同伴拒绝和同伴冲突等问题，
because we know that that's very, very common, unfortunately, for a lot of. lot of our teens and adults. So to give you an example of how we might handle sort of, you know, making new friends, meeting new people. So we mentioned that, you know, one of the things that people often have to do in order to meet new friends is to go up and join conversations with people. But what do you think that most adults might tell a teen to do in that situation? Like imagine they're at a party, they don't really know anyone, and they want to get to know the other people. What would an adult tell that teen to do? Just go up, introduce yourself, find something in common? Okay, well, they definitely tell them to go up and introduce themselves. I mean,
因为我们知道，不幸的是，这对我们许多青少年和成年人来说是非常非常普遍的。为了举例说明我们如何处理结交新朋友、结识新人的问题。我们提到，人们为了结交新朋友通常要做的事情之一就是走过去加入别人的谈话。但你认为大多数成年人可能会告诉青少年在这种情况下该怎么做？比如想象他们在聚会上，他们真的不认识任何人，他们想认识其他人。成年人会告诉那个青少年做什么？直接走过去，自我介绍，找共同点？好的，他们肯定会告诉他们走过去自我介绍。我的意思是，
we hear that time and time again from kids. They're also told up to go, they're told to go up and say hi. But if you step back and you really think about what that would look like, I mean, imagine if a teen were to walk up to another group of teens and say hi, you know, and kind of wave their hand or even worse, say hi, you know, I'm Liz and kind of put their hand out to shake hands. That's not really what kids who are socially accepted are naturally doing It's not what we call an ecologically valid social skill, what people who are socially accepted would naturally do. So in peers, what we try to do is actually teach what people who are socially accepted do in these real world situations. So instead of going up and saying hi or going up and introducing ourselves, instead of what we would teach our kids to do is first start by just kind of listening and watching the conversation.
我们一次又一次地从孩子们那里听到这一点。他们也被告知走过去说声嗨。但如果你退后一步，真正思考一下那会是什么样子，我的意思是，想象一下如果一个青少年走到另一群青少年面前说嗨，你知道，挥挥手，或者更糟的是，说嗨，我是利兹，并伸出手去握手。这并不是那些在社交上被接受的孩子自然而然会做的事情。这不是我们所说的生态有效的社交技能，即在社交上被接受的人自然会做的事情。所以在PEERS中，我们尝试做的是真正教授那些在现实世界中被社交接受的人会做的事情。所以，我们不是教孩子走过去说嗨或自我介绍，而是教他们首先从倾听和观察谈话开始。
And you mentioned something a moment ago. What do you think we're kind of watching and listening for? We're listening for an end, some way to join the conversation that would be. interesting. Yeah, and you kind of mentioned about sort of this common interest, right? So we're listening for the topic, first of all, and we're trying to make sure that we actually have something in common with the people that are talking, that we know something about the topic, that we have something to contribute. Now, while we're doing that, do you think that we should be sort of staring at the group as we're listening? Seems awkward. It would be a little bit awkward. Yeah,
你刚才提到了什么。你认为我们是在观察和倾听什么？我们是在听一个结尾，某种加入谈话的方式，那会很有趣。是的，你提到了共同兴趣，对吧？所以我们首先是在听话题，我们试图确保我们确实与正在交谈的人有共同点，我们了解这个话题，我们有东西可以贡献。现在，当我们这样做的时候，你认为我们在倾听时应该盯着那群人看吗？看起来很尴尬。那会有点尴尬。是的，
we probably don't want to stare at them. So what a lot of people do is they'll actually use a prop. They'll have a phone or like a gaming device or something like that, but they'll be kind of looking at their phone, maybe appearing like they're looking at text messages or something, but really they're eavesdropping. We just don't want to look like we're eavesdropping. So once we've sort of listened, figured out what the topic is, and decided that we want to join this conversation,
我们可能不想盯着他们看。所以很多人实际上会使用道具。他们会拿着手机或游戏设备之类的东西，但他们会盯着手机看，看起来好像在看短信之类的，但实际上是在偷听。我们只是不想看起来像是在偷听。所以一旦我们听到了，弄清楚了话题是什么，并决定我们想加入这个谈话，
we're going to wait for something. So what do you think we're waiting for? A pause? Yeah, exactly. We're waiting for a pause in the conversation. Now, why do we need a pause in the conversation before we join? We don't want to interrupt them, basically, right? So we want to wait for a little pause.
我们就会等待某种东西。所以你认为我们在等什么？停顿？是的，完全正确。我们在等谈话中的停顿。现在，为什么我们在加入之前需要谈话中的停顿？我们不想打断他们，对吧？所以我们要等一个小停顿。
We'll move a little bit closer. And then as we join, we make some kind of a comment or ask a question that's on topic. Now, those are very, very concrete steps for what we call peer entry. But do you think that, you know, a kid with autism could actually pick up on these steps and learn how to actually do that? It seems like it would be challenging for them to learn that. It can be challenging, but the great thing is that not only do we rely on these concrete kind of rules and steps of social behavior, which is actually, by the way, a really helpful way of teaching kids with autism because they think so concretely and so literally, we're taking something that seems abstract and we're making it very black and white for them. But it's not just enough to actually teach them those rules and steps.
我们会稍微靠近一点。然后当我们加入时，我们会发表某种评论或提出一个切题的问题。现在，这些是所谓的同伴进入的非常非常具体的步骤。但你认为，你知道，一个自闭症孩子真的能掌握这些步骤并学会如何真正做到这一点吗？这看起来对他们来说学习起来会很有挑战性。这可能具有挑战性，但好消息是，我们不仅依赖这些具体的社交行为规则和步骤（顺便说一下，这对教自闭症孩子非常有帮助，因为他们的思维非常具体和字面化），我们正在把一些看起来抽象的东西变得对他们来说非常黑白分明。但仅仅教他们这些规则和步骤是不够的。
Next, we actually have to demonstrate what that looks like, and that's where the role playing comes in. We do a lot of role playing demonstrations in our groups of sort of the social skills that you want to use, but also the behaviors that you don't want to engage in. So we show good and bad examples of social behavior. And then we kind of have them take on the perspectives of the other people and ask them things like, you know, what do you think that was like for that group of people? What do you think they thought of them? You know, I want to talk to them again, those sorts of things. And from there, the next step is that there should be some kind of a behavior rehearsal
接下来，我们实际上必须演示那是什么样子，这就是角色扮演发挥作用的地方。我们在小组中做了很多角色扮演演示，展示你想要使用的社交技能，但也展示你不想要参与的行为。所以我们展示了社交行为的好坏例子。然后我们让他们站在其他人的角度，问他们诸如，你知道，你认为那群人对此感觉如何？你认为他们是怎么看他们的？你知道，我想再和他们谈谈，诸如此类的事情。从那里，下一步应该是某种行为排练，
where they're practicing the newly learned skills. We're giving them coaching in the moment because, as you say, they don't get it right away. They're not going to master it perfectly. And then to generalize these skills to other settings, we need to actually provide some kind of homework assignment where they're practicing the skill in the real world, essentially. What about younger children with autism? I'm sure this is something that concerns parents and teachers, trying to get them to engage more socially. Is there anything that you do differently with younger children? You know, one of the things that's sort of unique about peers is that it's actually a parent-assisted program.
他们在练习新学到的技能。我们正在即时给他们指导，因为正如你所说，他们不会马上就学会。他们不会完美地掌握它。然后为了将这些技能推广到其他环境，我们需要提供某种家庭作业，本质上让他们在现实世界中练习这项技能。那么患有自闭症的年幼儿童呢？我相信这是家长和老师关心的问题，试图让他们更多地参与社交。对于年幼的儿童，你们有什么不同的做法吗？你知道，PEERS比较独特的一点是，它实际上是一个家长辅助的项目。
You know, the vast majority of social skills programs do not include parents or caregivers in the treatment. And I think that's a really big mistake because parents act as social coaches to their kids all the time. But as we just discovered in that last example, the advice that they give isn't always the best advice. They might tell their kid to go up and say hello or go up and say hi. So instead we want to include them on the treatment. And so that's what sort of makes our program unique. And in addition to working with adolescents and teens and their parents, we also work with younger kids through our program. We have a program that just was recently developed called Peers for Preschoolers, for example.
你知道，绝大多数社交技能项目在治疗中不包括家长或照顾者。我认为这是一个非常大的错误，因为家长一直充当他们孩子的社交教练。但正如我们在上一个例子中发现的那样，他们给出的建议并不总是最好的建议。他们可能会告诉他们的孩子走过去说你好或走过去说嗨。所以我们想把他们纳入治疗中。这就是让我们的项目独特的地方。除了与青少年及其家长合作外，我们还通过我们的项目与年幼的孩子合作。我们有一个刚开发不久的项目，叫做“学龄前儿童PEERS”，例如。
And this program actually works with preschool kids with autism spectrum disorder. And we're teaching social skills using that same method of very concrete rules and steps of social behavior. They're much more simplified, of course. I can imagine. But then also including parents on that and providing role play demonstrations and behavioral rehearsal opportunities, lots of homework assignments, and helping parents to learn how to organize things like playdates for their kids. You know, really the crux of all of this really comes down to social interaction and engagement with peers.
这个项目实际上是与患有自闭症谱系障碍的学龄前儿童合作。我们使用同样的方法，即非常具体的社交行为规则和步骤来教授社交技能。当然，它们简化了很多。我可以想象。但同时也包括家长，并提供角色扮演演示和行为排练机会，大量的家庭作业，并帮助家长学习如何为他们的孩子组织游戏约会。你知道，这一切的核心实际上归结为社交互动和与同伴的接触。
And for younger kids, that really is the responsibility of a parent. For older, you know, adolescents and for adults, that's their responsibility, and they can use support from their parents. But for our younger kids, they need a lot more support in providing these social opportunities. So the parent involvement, I think, is really the key piece to the success of this program. Is there anything else that you wanted to talk about, anything exciting that you're working on with peers? Sure. Yeah, we're working on a lot of really exciting things right now. So I've talked a lot about the parent assistant portion of this program that we include parents as
对于年幼的孩子，这确实是家长的责任。对于年龄较大的青少年和成年人，那是他们的责任，他们可以利用家长的支持。但对于我们年幼的孩子，他们在提供这些社交机会方面需要更多的支持。所以我认为家长的参与是这个项目成功的关键。还有什么你想谈的吗，有什么你在PEERS中正在做的令人兴奋的事情吗？当然。是的，我们现在正在做很多非常令人兴奋的事情。所以我谈了很多关于这个项目的家长辅助部分，我们通过PEERS将家长作为
social coaches to their kids through peers. We've also done some work in the schools where we actually include teachers as the social coaches. And in this case, these programs are teacher facilitated. We teach social skills in the classroom, much like we would teach math or science, something like that using these very concrete rules and steps. And we have a school-based manual that's actually coming out now that's based on the research that we've done with our peers' school-based program. So we're very excited about that. And that's due out in October 2013. So that's something to look for. And we also have another resource that will be available to families. And that's a parent book that's coming out in September of 2013. And that's called The Science of Making Friends.
他们孩子的社交教练。我们还在学校做了一些工作，实际上将老师作为社交教练。在这种情况下，这些项目是由老师推动的。我们在课堂上教授社交技能，就像我们教授数学或科学一样，使用这些非常具体的规则和步骤。我们有一本基于学校的手册，现在正在出版，它是基于我们用PEERS学校项目所做的研究。所以我们对此感到非常兴奋。该手册将于2013年10月出版。所以这是值得期待的。我们还有另一个资源将提供给家庭。那是一本将于2013年9月出版的家长书。书名叫《交友的科学》。
And the idea behind this book is that we're actually trying to provide the skills, the rules and steps of social behavior that we teach in peers to families that might not be able to access a peers program in their community or their school. You know, we work really hard on trying to disseminate our program throughout the world, really. We do trainings all over the globe, but the reality is that you can't access a peers program in every community. And because we know parents are very desperate, very often, to help. their kids with their social skills. We've provided this parent book, The Science of Making Friends. So we're real excited about that.
这本书背后的想法是，我们实际上试图为那些可能无法在社区或学校获得PEERS项目的家庭提供我们在PEERS中教授的社交行为技能、规则和步骤。你知道，我们非常努力地试图在全世界传播我们的项目。我们在全球各地进行培训，但现实情况是，你不可能在每个社区都能获得PEERS项目。因为我们知道家长们通常非常渴望帮助他们的孩子提高社交技能。我们提供了这本家长书《交友的科学》。所以我们对此感到非常兴奋。
Well, it sounds like you have a lot going on. It's very exciting. Thank you so much for joining us today. Well, thank you so much for having me. For more information on the Peers program, please visit our website at APA.org slash speaking of psychology. Thank you for joining us.
嗯，听起来你有很多事情要做。这非常令人兴奋。非常感谢您今天加入我们。嗯，非常感谢您的邀请。有关PEERS项目的更多信息，请访问我们的网站APA.org/speaking of psychology。感谢您的收听。
I'm Audrey Hamilton with the American Psychological Association's Speaking of Psychology. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是奥黛丽·汉密尔顿，来自美国心理学会的《心理学谈话》。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。